listen if you really cared about the
baby what you would have did you said
hey man you need to sit down with magic
johnson y'all need to have a
conversation on tape this is required
for me
he will educate you and you lace magic
with the tips and they have a
conversation that's recorded you put it
on tv educate people let this man go get
his [ __ ] money but again it's not
about that it's about [ __ ] you better
watch what you say
it ain't about none of that other [ __ ]
it's a thousand [ __ ] that said
worse
but [ __ ] watch what you say you getting
out of line [ __ ] you you feel me we you
getting out of control well i think what
you said too is like a lot of this [ __ ]
is about saving face or or or acting
like you care right so if you're
if as soon as one festival took them off
you knew
any other festival that kept them on
would look like a promotion point oh no
they're homophobic
or or like you said all the festivals
that took them off you saw it on the
shade room you saw their flyer on every
single news outlet so it was like not
only is it
free promotion but it also checks the
box of like okay we kind of have to do
this because one [ __ ] took them
off
if they if every other festival doesn't
follow suit they're gonna get looked at
like they're they're homophobic
and i think i just think that like like
you said like
i liked what miley cyrus posted because
she was like i would like to educate him
as opposed to and then he's not [ __ ] i
hate him l john come out like bro you
don't even use your twitter bro madonna
what the [ __ ]
bro you ain't getting nothing that
matters do you think that it was smart
for him to though like lean into it yeah
cause you're a [ __ ] gangster rapper
you're a [ __ ] gangster that's fair
feel me but the only the only thing as
long as he's okay with losing the
revenue that they was providing for him
he'll be fine but obviously he wasn't he
came out and apologized and that's what
he's probably getting three four hundred
a show yeah but you gotta make your own
three four hundred i don't disagree with
you but i'm just saying well i mean you
know after the seventh or eighth one you
start adding up that money i went
through the same because the baby but
whether we like it or not he's a
gangster rapper he's also a pop star but
that's the but that's the point because
he is a gangster rapper that's fair so
the first time you turn it to a pop star
stop being a gangster rapper it's
probably not gonna work out